from behind-the-scenes bond mo to how
the film might even be connected to get
out and early prognosticating for its
oscar chances here's what you need to
know before you see acclaimed filmmaker
Jordan peels 2019 horror Audi us after
getting this start on the sketch comedy
series MADtv where he spent five seasons
it might have seemed unlikely that
Jordan Peele would soon shoot to the
upper echelon of filmmakers and earn
himself an Academy Award
but once audiences got to see his
whip-smart social satire on Key & Peele
the hit sketch show starring Peele and
his comedic scene partner keegan-michael
key they may have realized what a bright
future pelé had ahead of him from his
pitch perfect Obama impression to his
enthusiastic valet peel quickly made his
mark on sketch comedy before setting his
sights even higher to perfection Bill's
2017 film get out chronicling an
extremely bad weekend away for Chris at
his girlfriend's family's country house
ended up making its mark as the most
profitable film of the year as well as
netting an Academy Award for Best
Original Screenplay for Peele along with
nominations for Best Director and Best
Picture bill has since retired from
acting noting that he prefers directing
but word is that he hasn't changed
despite moving behind the camera he
brought his Obama impression back among
others to lighten the mood on set during
get out after get out which paired
veteran actors like Bradley Whitford and
Catherine Keener alongside lesser-known
performers like Daniel Kaluga and
Allison Williams Pele had to assemble a
noteworthy cast for a second film and he
certainly didn't disappoint two of the
first names announced were Winston Duke
and Lupita Nyong'o the former of whom is
known for roles in persons of interest
and other small film and television
roles while the latter made an
unforgettable debut in Steve McQueen's
12 years of slave while she was still
attending Yale Drama School and even won
an Academy Award for her work the two
actors also notably appeared together in
2018 s Black Panther the juggernaut
Marvel superhero film starring chadwick
boseman and Michael B Jordan that
crushed box-office records
aside from Duke and Nyong'o the film
features two other stars
Miller two TV vans Elizabeth moss and
Tim Heidecker who are known for vastly
different projects Elizabeth moss rose
to fame on Sirius prestige dramas like
Mad Men and the Handmaid's Tale while
high Decker's biggest claim to fame is
his work on the Adult Swim original Tim
and Eric awesome show great job hi me
mama Tim Heidecker and welcome to
discount pricing 19.7 1969 she after get
out which was a completely original
concept for a social thriller many fans
probably expected Pele to produce a new
and completely original concept but it's
important to recognize the genesis of us
came from one of the best works of
horror in history when Pele was only a
kid he watched the 1960 episode of The
Twilight Zone called mirror-image about
a woman waiting for a bus on a rainy
evening who spots her exact duplicate
after a series of odd and disconcerting
events convinced that her double is sent
from an alternate universe to replace
her
the woman begins to unravel and has
eventually carted away even though her
double is all too real this isn't peels
only brush with the famous horror
anthology series he's producing and
hosting the next generation of The
Twilight Zone which will air on CBS in
2019 though there have been a few
Twilight Zone reboots since the original
series aired this one is perhaps the
most highly anticipated since us is
following one of the most beloved films
of 2017 it's natural that fans would
want to find connections between the two
and theories have run rampant as to how
they might be linked an obvious
connection is how Pele plays with the
issues of the subconscious from the
stolen bodies and get out to the
mysterious doubles in us representing a
stolen or other consciousness taken from
the protagonists the trailer for us
seems to feature some pretty overt
similarities to get out as well
including plenty of shots of driving as
well as a straight-on shot of a tear
soaked Nyong'o that clearly echoes the
most famous shot of get out from there
the theories get pretty intense from the
importance of scissors as it pertains to
severing links within one soul to the
possibility that the family in US has
undergone the central surgery from get
out it's all pretty wild but considering
that Pele once told a journal
she wanted to weave in the universe of
get out into future films maybe nothing
is off-limits get out was a perfect
entry into horror from many viewers
despite just a few jump scares and
plenty of gore for good measure the film
relied on emotional and psychological
trauma instead of traditional horror and
was even funny at times but in the end
it wasn't meant as a classic horror film
with Peale himself calling it a social
thriller in the vein of Alfred Hitchcock
rather than a true horror movie I mean
how you will scare a couple of dolls
with a plot don't be stupid every early
report on us however has noted its full
leap into horror after early screenings
critics and fans flocked to the Internet
to tell the world that us is much
scarier than get out genre fans should
be excited for this next chapter in
peels filmography but for those who love
peels off beat sense of humor there's no
need to worry
reports from screenings note that
audiences were often warring with
laughter and thanks to peels sharp
comedic timing mixed with his incisive
social statements us is sure to deliver
as much of a gut-punching message as its
predecessor peels second film has been
hotly anticipated since get out
conquered the box office and after he
announced in February of 2018 that he
would be working on a second film fans
of horror and key & peele alike had been
waiting though the wide release of the
film was originally supposed to take
place on March 15 2019 the producers and
peel wisely bumped it back to March 22nd
after US landed an opening night slot at
the South by Southwest Film Festival
where it's screened to overwhelming
acclaim reactions were universally
adoring for the frightening film but
fans noting that it was everything from
terrifying to gorgeous to stunningly
acted driving up enthusiasm for those
who didn't get the chance to check out
us in Austin Jordan Peele broke several
Oscar barriers with his debut film he
walked away with the statue for Best
Original Screenplay making history as
the first black screenwriter to ever win
the award with this highly pedigreed
background it seems all been inevitable
that US will be a serious contender in
the next award season but thanks to his
genre that isn't guaranteed only six
horror films have ever been nominated
for Best Picture
and horror films and the performances
within our frequently overlooked with
plenty of oscar veterans in the cast us
may stand a chance but it remains to be
seen whether academy voters will let
four films back into the fray so soon
after get out when fans and reviewers
start wondering about us as oscar
chances the first mentions will likely
go to neon goes leading performance
since winning an Oscar the star has kept
plenty busy appearing on Broadway and
eclipsed as well as joining the Star
Wars universe as motion capture
character Maz Kanata her biggest post
Oscar project however was black panther
in which she appeared as Nakia a
wakandan spy and love interest to
chadwick boseman 'he's king T'Challa
joining the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
one of its highest-grossing films yet it
should come as no surprise then that
Nyong'o is being singled out for us
along with the rest of the main cast she
plays two parts Adelaide a wife and
mother as well as Adelaide's terrifying
double known only as red New York
Magazine describes in the young ghosts
performance as her own doppelganger as
an achievement on another level while
the Los Angeles Times notes that the
film belongs to Nyong'o with a modest
budget of 4.5 million dollars get out
would have been a success at the box
office even if it had a completely
average theatrical run but peels debut
grossed 255 million dollars worldwide
for the net profit of over a hundred and
twenty million dollars making it the
tenth most profitable film of 2017 as
well as earning the distinction of being
the highest grossing Original Screenplay
since the Blair Witch Project
thanks to get out success Pele was given
much more budgetary breathing room for
his follow-up Pele wanted more financial
flexibility and thanks to his
established success as well as the first
look deal that Universal made with his
production company monkey paw
productions he was afforded a twenty
million dollar budget for us by
increasing the budget but still keeping
it low enough that the studio would be
unlikely to interfere with the finished
product Pele walked a difficult line to
make sure he could make us exactly as he
planned
beneath the horror and the humour that
make up the backbone of peels
filmography lies a foundation of
involved complex messages and between
get out and us the
rector and writer has a lot to say about
America in get out Pele infused a
question of self-examination and with
all this in mind it made it even more
satisfying for viewers to watch Chris
escape at the end of the film knowing
that he could remain himself and keep
ownership of his body considered his
situation
could handle Pele and the cast of us
have kept details fairly close to the
vest remaining vague about specific plot
points but Pele has been clear about his
intentions noting that when groups or
individuals don't take clear looks at
themselves both as people and as
Americans evil is given the chance to
survive and thrive with the tethered the
doppelgangers in the film Pele can
express both an internal and
wide-reaching fear of others making
viewers really think as they leave the
theatre besides being a box-office smash
get out was a critical hit and cultural
phenomenon upon its release even
inspiring a college course on racism and
horror like its predecessor us racked up
plenty of raves before it's all wide
release following and get outs footsteps
to earn an initial 100 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes after its hit opening at South
by Southwest and early March
if audiences were worried about a
sophomore slump from Pele that doesn't
seem to be the case and though the score
may dip as more reviews come in this
stunning critical early showing is a
strong indicator for the film's future
reception and its potential box office
earnings adding another success to
Peale's career Jordan Peele is a
self-professed lifelong horror fan so it
shouldn't be surprising that he found
his way into the genre even if he did
get his start in side-splitting sketch
comedy shows
forget out spiel noted ahead of the
film's release that he took inspiration
from everything from classic films like
Rosemary's Baby and the Stepford Wives
when it came to informing tone and the
building of tension but considering that
US is reportedly much more classically
scary than get out it stands to reason
that Pele would have an entirely new
list of inspirations Pele revealed his
reading list of sorts well before us is
release and even told star Lupita
Nyong'o to watch 10 specific films so
that they could have a shared language
on set between classics like the birds
and the shining modern hits like the
babadook and foreign
films like let the right one in this
varied and diverse list is the perfect
primer for any horror fan that wants to
brush up before us check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]